así que para ting es la capacidad de
crear vida y eso es lo que te hace una
mujer la feminidad y la condición de una
mujer es mucho más que vestirse
colocarse maquillaje y la forma en la
que me siento es lo que soy hablando
desde un punto de vista biológico
[Música]
spectrum feministas
los hombres pueden ser feministas
321 ya
llevo una sudadera que dice que los
hombres pueden ser feministas siento que
tengo que estar aquí creo que la mayoría
de los hombres que son feministas suelen
ser o bien perezosos que señalan la
virtud o sólo quieren ver senos u
obtener sexo fácil y creo que depende de
tu definición de feminismo como
feminismo moderno diría que si el
feminismo tradicional que defiende la
feminidad y sabes la no discriminación
en el trabajo creo que son cosas con las
que los hombres pueden estar de acuerdo
entiendo lo que dices existe este
feminismo performativo que muchos chicos
hacen es algo así como yo solo apoyo a
las mujeres y sólo se trata de eso pero
ni siquiera habla de como el feminismo
necesita apoyar a los hombres oa las
personas trans o lo que sea entonces hay
una performatividad en ello las voces
feministas blancas hablan demasiado
estoy un poco de acuerdo en que las
voces feministas blancas hablan
demasiado pero luego creo que se vuelven
más buenas utilizando a las mujeres
negras o los rostros negros cuando
quieren impulsar su movimiento estoy de
acuerdo en que probablemente no es
equilibrado y creo que probablemente
debe ser más igualitario la razón por la
que estoy un poco en desacuerdo es
simplemente porque me resisto a decir
que cualquiera que defienda sus puntos
de vista habla demasiado creo que está
bien y puedo ver lo que dices solo odio
cuando algunos de estos movimientos
utilizan a las mujeres negras cuando les
conviene a ellos no se habla de las
inmigrantes latinas de cómo son tratadas
en el movimiento feminista siempre se
centran en hablar del lado pro elección
o de otra cosa que es más interesante
para los blancos cuando se piensa en el
feminismo suele ser una mujer blanca y
creo que eso se sigue perpetuando aunque
hayan muchas mujeres negras entre
bastidores que hacen mucho trabajo
pesado y a menudo están en muchos
movimientos de derechos civiles las
mujeres blancas tienen derechos que
necesitan a través
feminismo como otras personas pero
siempre son tomadas más en serio por
todo el mundo
figuras públicas voy a leer una lista de
personajes públicos y te irás a la
izquierda si crees que la persona es
feminista o la derecha si no crees que
lo sea kim kardashian
yo no diría que no es feminista no creo
que eso sea lo principal para ella paso
de hacer su programa y todo el asunto
del escándalo sexual ahora está
trabajando en leyes y derechos civiles y
ha hecho todo el asunto de la familia en
definitiva creo que kim kardashian es
una mujer que ha hecho lo que ha querido
hacer con su vida amy cón y verdad
amy cón y verde mi opinión es el epítome
de una feminista es literalmente una
jueza del tribunal supremo en el más
alto tribunal del país y desmiente
totalmente la narrativa de que las
mujeres tienen que elegir entre tener
una carrera y una familia no estoy muy
de acuerdo en cuanto a sus posturas
políticas pero creo que es un modelo a
seguir para las mujeres que quieren
estar al nivel del tribunal supremo que
está dominado principalmente por hombres
jk rowling
hace tres años habría dicho que sí y
todavía hay muchas razones para hacerlo
era madre soltera escribió los libros se
hizo multimillonaria la razón por la que
diría que no ahora es su extraño
fanatismo anti trans en el que se ha
involucrado y eso debilita muchas de sus
otras cosas feministas no estoy de
acuerdo en que sólo por el hecho de que
ella expresa sus propias opiniones ahora
la gente la crucifica y realmente quiere
rebajar la y socavar todo lo que ha
hecho entiende tiene una plataforma tan
grande que cuando se habla de estas
cosas tan extremas sobre un grupo
marginado allí está el problema porque
las mujeres con una plataforma deben ser
obligadas a alinearse con una narrativa
dominante de lo que significa ser una
mujer y una feminista porque no puede
ser suficiente su propio viaje
personalmente no es que sea una opinión
es que está difundiendo mucha y
peligrosa desinformación ado en que sólo
porque no estás de acuerdo
no son hechos científicos solo habla de
cosas que son incorrectas y sus ideas
sobre los hombres trans han afectado a
la legislación
perjudicándolos en la obtención de
recursos que necesitan las mujeres trans
son mujeres
321 ya
creo que todos nos posicionamos aquí en
base a nuestras creencias políticas y en
cuanto a cómo vemos a los lgtb te creo
que también está dividido entre todos
los hombres están de ese lado y las
mujeres están de este sé que siendo
mujer hay ciertas cosas que tenemos que
afrontar como mujeres que las personas
que no son biológicamente mujeres no
tienen que afrontar tenemos que lidiar
con la menstruación y pasar por esa
etapa realmente incómoda cuando tenemos
13 y las personas que son mujeres trans
no tienen que pasar por eso las mujeres
trans viven toda una vida como mujeres
no pueden
desconectarlo no es algo que apaguen y
puedan decir luego así veo que estás
haciendo esto pero no eres una mujer es
una especie de hobby es tu vida como
mujer porque cada vez que alguien dice
eso nombre a las cosas más
estereotipadas es como ponerse un
vestido o maquillarse es biológico
entonces todo es biológico su nombre no
importa así que sigo siendo biólogo no
conocerlo y son solo cromosomas ella
está las diferencias son solo cromosomas
solo tener hijos eso es tan hiriente y
discriminatorio para las mujeres porque
la feminidad y la condición de la mujer
es mucho más que vestirse y maquillarse
y la forma en la que me siento es lo que
soy desde un punto de vista biológico
así que para ti es la capacidad de crear
vida y eso es lo que te hace una mujer
que te hace ser un hombre o cómo te
consideras un hombre debería ser la
perfección así como hombre me comporto
como un hombre me dice buena sociedad un
hombre como tú si quiero ser una mejor
hemos estar de acuerdo en que nuestra
sociedad tiene cosas que los hombres
hacen y las mujeres hacen si empiezas a
caer en un lado del espectro frente al
otro lado del espectro vas a ser tratado
como ese género creo que es un poco
oscuro que lo veamos como un requisito
tan básico los humanos están mucho más
evolucionados que cualquier otro animal
así que porque seguimos utilizando el
requisito de esa persona tiene un pene
es macho o esa persona tiene una vagina
es hembra creo que eres una mujer
masculina o un hombre femenino eso no te
convierte en ese género y tratar de
negar hechos biológicos básicos que
todos aprendemos en la escuela
secundaria dejemos de actuar como si
fuera algo nuevo y diferente ahora
porque es lo que está de moda de creo
que se confunde mucho el hecho de ser
hembra con el de ser mujer ser hembra es
algo cromosómico es lo que se nace ser
una mujer es una construcción social si
pueden alinearse los tuyos obviamente se
alinean dijiste estás como todos los
hombres por aquí los primeros 30 años de
mi vida fui una mujer hice la transición
es una desconexión con lo que naces y lo
que sientes que debes disforia de género
exacto de acuerdo puedo creerlo puedo
creerlo completamente sí sí solo
quisiera ser una mujer masculina
entonces claro eso es fácil de hacer
pero eso no funcionó no voy a decir que
soy hombre en una sí
x y eso nunca cambiará y ninguna persona
trans te dirá que ha nacido
biológicamente así porque si alguien
sabe algo de biología son las personas
trans por eso tienen que hormonarse y
hacer todas todo eso y no te quita tu
condición de mujer si otra persona es un
tipo de mujer diferente es una
experiencia diferente que no debería
hacerte sentir menos mujer si están
cerca o viceversa crees que el
movimiento feminista debería luchar por
las mujeres trans dentro de ese
movimiento
deberían luchar por los géneros de todos
ya sean mujeres u hombres trans mujeres
u hombres si son personas no binarias
eso es parte del feminismo no lo creo
creo que eso hace fracasar todo el
movimiento
todas las feministas deberían estar a
favor del aborto
321 ya
me considero en realidad una feminista
pro-vida y creo que la idea de que
podamos decir a las mujeres que no
pueden identificarse como feministas a
menos que digan que son pro abortistas
creo que va totalmente en contra de todo
lo que el feminismo representa estoy de
acuerdo con eso y creo que eso es algo
hermoso de la feminidad y de las mujeres
en general y algo que muestra que el
feminismo moderno ha sido un poco
excluyente porque las mujeres provienen
de todos los orígenes y procesos de
pensamiento diferentes y creo que
debemos apoyar la libertad de elección
la libertad de expresión sin importar el
estilo de vida de cada mujer si
personalmente te sientes que eres
pro-vida está bien el feminismo como
movimiento debería ser pro elección para
permitir a cualquiera elegir el camino
que quiera tener ya sea tener hijos o no
tenerlos o abortar o lo que sea pero si
el feminismo es pro-vida entonces ha
bloqueado un grupo de personas de elegir
si quieren tener abortos su propia
planificación familia uno de los
argumentos que me gustaría dar es que
creo que el aborto es tremendamente
discriminatorio para las mujeres y
también para las personas con
discapacidad las niñas son abordadas de
mayor proporción lo que es muy sexista
así que realmente no creo que pueda ser
feminista y estar a favor del aborto
porque son prácticas discriminatorias
soy pro elección creo que alguien
debería tener el tipo de elección que
quiera hacer deben poder elegir en
cuanto a oye este es mi cuerpo y quiero
poder abortar o igualmente quiero decir
voy a tener este bebé
creo que depende al 100% de la mujer una
feminista tal vez debería estar más
alineada con dar a alguien su propia
elección los productos menstruales
deberían ser gratuitos
321 ya
y estoy por colocar un ejemplo en las
escuelas de bajos ingresos hay muchas
chicas que no pueden permitírselo y se
avergüenzan de pedirlo personalmente
creo que aunque no se haya hablado de
cosas como los productos menstruales o
incluso en la parte sanitaria creo que
debería añadirse creo que todo el mundo
debería ser compensado por su trabajo y
creo que crear y producir productos
menstruales es un servicio y que la
gente pues debe cobrar nadie está
diciendo que no cobren porque como tú
has dicho naciste mujer no pediste tener
la menstruación así que ahora tienes que
salir a pagar más impuestos que yo
porque yo no tengo que comprar tienes
hampones o lo que sea es una pandemia de
mujeres que sangran a través de sus
ropas o algo así porque he trabajado con
familias de bajos ingresos nunca he oído
hablar de este tema salvo en las redes
sociales
ahora bien hay casos o puede haber
segmentos en la vida de las personas en
los que necesitan cosas necesitan ayuda
o necesitan que la comunidad
absolutamente pero no creo que sea esta
enorme crisis que todo el mundo está
haciendo ver simplemente no la he visto
toda mujer debería ser feminista
321 ya
una vez más siento que eso va en contra
de todo lo que el feminismo defiende al
citar que una mujer tiene que pensar de
cierta manera toda mujer debería ser
feminista en lugar de tiene que ser
feminista por eso en cierto modo estoy
muy de acuerdo si debería ser feminista
si eres mujer por qué deberías querer la
igualdad volviendo atrás crees que la
gente ha malinterpretado la palabra
feminismo la mayoría de las mujeres
deberían ser feministas pero ya lo son
para mí lo son no conozco a ninguna
mujer que no sea feminista pero no se
llaman a sí mismas así por el feminismo
extremo por ejemplo a mí me gusta servir
a mi marido eso es algo que me gusta eso
no hace que no sea feminista eso es lo
que soy a él le gusta hacer otras cosas
cómo cambiar mis neumáticos nunca haré
eso así soy yo no soy feminista y esto
es oficialmente el final chicos muy bien
me gustó choca esos cinco muy bien
[Risas]
buen trabajo
por todos lados
muy bien amigos